rudy giuliani is having a little trouble
being ghosted by trump and it's not
surprising that trump was not going to
pay this [ __ ]
number one rudy giuliani was grifting
trump trying to charge him
massive amounts of [ __ ]
fees for a fraud of
election fraud the big lie as it were
and you thought you you were out
perpetuating this big lie
[ __ ] that was completely false i mean
jesus christ rudy giuliani went
and testified in front of state
legislator and purged himself
because he said the exact opposite
things in these state legislators
that he was saying in federal court when
he had to be in front of a judge which
the the cost of perjury would cost him
his law license
which it did in the state of new york
so now trump's not gonna pay him who
should be [ __ ] surprised by that
no one should be [ __ ] surprised by
this nobody
[ __ ] nobody
but rudy giuliani is in a lot of legal
trouble here with this ukraine thing
and somehow rudy giuliani it keeps
coming back
you hear this joel greenberg case and
apparently joel greenberg has petitioned
to prolong
the sentencing hearing for him to be
sentenced
in in his plea deal that he before he
pled guilty to sex trafficking
and the reason why i think that's
significant to the rudy giuliani the
donald trump thing
is because joel greenberg apparently
petitioned giuliani and roger stone
and jared kushner to get them to lobby
and paid them
is the word 250 thousand dollars which
if he really did pay
roger stone to to to petition
kushner and giuliani to go lobby the
president of the united states donald
trump at that time
if he really did pay him 250 000 i would
imagine
that goal joel greenberg has that venmo
receipt
he had all the other venmo receipts from
all the other crimes he was committing
with matt gatz
and all the underage prostitutes taking
them across the state lines and state
borders and
paying for drugs and prostitution all
kinds of [ __ ] on your venmo so surely
he's got that venmo receive
receipt i'm sure joel greenberg that is
but giuliani appears in this case
this is crossover from the ukraine case
so he's he he that the probe the fbi
probe that caused the raid
was was the quit pro quo where he was
acting as a foreign agent
and he was using quid pro quo and using
using
what he didn't have authority over which
was
united states aid to ukraine
as a quid pro quo to get the ukrainian
government ukrainian president
in particular to come out make false
public statements about joe biden
because they were scared joe biden was
gonna beat them hmm i wonder why
probably because it sucks to suck that's
why they were scared of joe biden
they [ __ ] suck their ideas [ __ ]
suck they know that we know that their
ideas [ __ ] suck
and they know that we know that they
know that we know that their ideas
[ __ ] suck
and that's why they were terrified of
joe biden
terrified of him because he was going to
stop the [ __ ] out of him
that's why they tried to cheat to win
that's why they keep saying oh the
democrats cheated the democrats cheated
oh the election was rigged they tried to
rig the election that they're trying to
rig the next one
with all the voter suppression laws
they're trying to rig the next
[ __ ]
and they're surprised that they didn't
win because they tried to rig it
russia russia are you on line one are
you on line one
we missed you we thought you were going
to help us in 2020 can you help us in
2022
that's that's why putin didn't want
[ __ ] biden to be the goddamn
president in the first place
putin didn't the actual president that
we had the last four years
you know they love putin they're putin's
puppets
but rudy giuliani shows up in the
ukraine case and he shows up in the joel
greenberg case
and it's funny to me and uh yeah i just
find it hilarious
funny it's kind of odd
that joel greenberg is asking to prolong
his sentencing
now the reason why you prolong your
sentencing is because
you're trying to give as much [ __ ] as
you possibly can to get your federal
prison sentence lowered because joel
greenberg
pleading guilty to the charges he's
pleading guilty to this guy is not going
to go to a cushy federal prison camp
that's not where he's going he is not
going to a federal
prison camp that's not where he's going
he's going to be a chomo he's going to
be a sex offender
he was sex trafficking so he's going to
go either to a low
or a medium or
a specific prison
for sexual predators is where he's going
to go
when he's sentenced which is not a low
uh no security prison
they are real [ __ ] prisons he's gonna
serve a real [ __ ] prison sentence
in federal prison a real one
so he is not going he is going to try
everything he can do
to keep that actual prison sentence
lowered
so the longer he has to keep feeding
information
to prosecutors to get them on his good
side for his guilty plea
the better off he is in the end in the
sentencing hearing when the magistrate
sentences him and the prosecutors say
well he was very cooperative in all
these cases look at all the evidence
that he gave us
look at all the other prosecutions that
we got roger stone rudy giuliani
jared kushner donald trump matt gatz
because you know matt gatz is gonna flip
too
right this motherfucker's gonna flip too
he showed up at trump's [ __ ] nazi
rally in florida or whatever that thing
was
and he's all soaking wet out in the rain
trying to gain uh favor with donald
trump
and the trump supporters so that way
when he flips they don't think it's him
he's gonna flip he's gonna flip that
that
he that rube is gonna flip he's gonna be
terrified
of federal prison the same way joe
greenberg's terrified of it
that's why joel greenberg flipped it's
because
someone got to joel greenberg and told
him the truth look
if you go to trial and a jury convicts
you of what these charges are
you are completely and utterly [ __ ]
you will go to a
high security federal prison and you
will be branded
as a sexual predator in that prison and
it will not be good for you
it will not be good it's not good
the federal prison camps not so bad
maybe
some people call him cushy you are not
going there
that is not the prison you are going to
like michael cohen and paul manafort and
roger
stone if he would have went to prison
they would have went to federal prison
camps joe greenberg is not going there
matt gatz when he gets charged with sex
trafficking
and he flips and has to plea he's going
to try to plea out
of any kind of sexual crime so he can go
to a federal prison camp
that's how it's gonna work that's why
matt gatz is gonna flip
when they pull him in to this [ __ ]
probe if he's not already flipping
which that's probably the case that's
probably why matt gatz has not been
charged yet
is because he is flipping he is talking
he is giving receipts
that's probably why and he's probably
backing everything that joel greenberg
says
that's why they're prolonging this
sentencing hearing
is so that they can gather as much [ __ ]
on someone else
which if you look at the joel greenberg
matt get scheme
there's only one way up it's roger stone
getting paid to lobby rudy giuliani who
shows up
in an fbi probe and a raid for the
ukraine deal
and jared kushner on january 17th
people january go back and look go back
and [ __ ] look on january 17th rudy
giuliani
ivanka trump and jared kushner went to
the white house
to lobby the orange deity the
the cheeto mussolini jesus
they lobbied them for pardons that day
i mean i'm just surmising allegedly
they allegedly lobbied him for pardons
well the word is is that joel greenberg
gave roger stone 250
000 to convince
giuliani and kushner to go lobby trump
for a pardon of all the crimes that he
has now pled guilty to which
joel greenberg obviously did not get a
pardon for
or he wouldn't have to plead guilty to
them
i believe that there's a possibility
that mr gatz was on the list for that
250 000 dollars
i guess that could be a possibility how
could it not be a possibility
in this scheme of course this could be a
possibility
in this scheme and and there has to be
someone
if joel greenberg is at the top of this
scheme as he is already pled guilty
there would be no reason for the federal
court to prolong
his sentencing there would be no reason
no reason
absolutely no reason if joel greenberg
is the only one that's going to get
prosecuted in this case
and joel greenberg is the end of the
line the head the head
the big fish as they call it the big
fish
they would be sentencing him they would
not be prolonging it
there would be no reason to prolong it
other than
prosecutors joel greenberg
the courts believe that there is a
bigger fish
the grand jury believes that there is a
bigger fish
that somewhere inside this sealed deal
this plea deal the seal plea deal that
they made
because there's a seal plea deal there's
the one that we see and then a seal one
that no one else sees
that only the court see to protect joe
greenberg
and what he's saying to prosecutors
so in that there's something that's
saying hey there's bigger fish here
bigger fish and
matt gats been mowing a couple times to
joel greenberg
for underage prostitutes allegedly that
using his venmo account publicly which
is kind of stupid but you know
that that that is not bigger fish than
what they charge
joel greenberg with they had like 22
charges against this [ __ ]
that's pretty goddamn big fish if you
want my opinion
but rudy giuliani shows up in this case
rudy shows up in the joel greenberg case
when you talk about 250 000 going up the
ladder to roger stone
rudy giuliani and jared kushner
possibly possibly lobbying the president
at the time donald j
trump for a pardon for joel greenberg
and wouldn't you think matt gatts would
be on that list now i did a video
i did a video on january 17th about rudy
giuliani going to the white house
to petition the orange mussolini jesus
for these pardons now i surmised that it
was only his name on the napkin that he
had
written out for the pardons that he
wanted the list of pardons on a napkin
i surmised that it was only rudy
giuliani's name on that list
but now i'm starting to think that it
was not just rudy giuliani and
it had joel greenberg's name uh a lot of
names
possibly matt gatz's name possibly i
don't know
but matt gatz is not the big fish i
don't think roger stone is the big fish
i think that's why roger stone's losing
his goddamn bind
is because he didn't flip on trump the
last time he was in federal trouble
is he gonna flip on him this time i
don't know
i mean if he gets tied up in this joel
greenberg case he may or he may not
but that's what they're searching for
bigger fish bigger fish bigger fish
bigger fish bigger fish
and that's where rudy giuliani and the
federal fbi raid
on his apartment with the ukraine deal
with the with the whole first
impeachment ukraine quid pro quo
he shows up in that federal case he's
going to show up in the joel greenberg
case
and it's all tying together with the
federal indictments
with with the inauguration committee i'm
sure
i'm sure that's going to have a lot to
do with it but rudy giuliani is very
desperate for his legal money his legal
funds
he needs cash now call jg
wentworth if you need cash now i don't
even know if i've got that right it's
been a while since i've seen that
commercial
but i did use that at the beginning of
the video you get it you [ __ ] get it
you get it